[Musique]
non
c'est toujours difficile pour moi
d'aider réalisé 6 est vraiment passé
parce qu'ils aient accepté la perte et
des moments harris a été vraiment déçu
pour moi aurait lui il est énorme très
généré il aimait beaucoup ses enfants il
m'aimait beaucoup c'est un homme qui
aimait aider aussi beaucoup de gens nous
les manques au vraiment
où
hamon par terre c'était la joie de vie
c'était jusqu'à la fin le sourire les
blagues on peut y avait toujours une
blague
c'était l'humour c'était un sourire son
bonheur que la musique sont monast
d'avoir sa famille ou tourner lui ses
enfants
je travaille allez demain de la santé et
pendant la pandémie
notre centre d'hébergement a été
infectée alors c'est j'ai contacté la
maladie le gérer ça au niveau de mon
travail mais moi je ne savais pas si
j'étais malade parce que je ne
présentait pas de symptômes et quelques
jours après c'est lui qui a commencé à
me dit que non il se sent comme si c'est
les débits des grippes et mon mari a
commencé à faire difficultés
respiratoires
[Musique]
ces vermines qui colle à transférer
l'otage sur deux mois
là il est demeuré dans le coma
artificiel l'a fait au moins 38 jours
d'aller pour moi oui on perd fried de
démence depuis quelques années où vous
voulez vraiment le garder à la maison le
plus longtemps possible
le ch à celle du bassin vraiment été une
solution où on n'avait pas le choix
[Musique]
et
c'est toujours une décision difficile
pour nous ça a été un 1er 2 ça a été
pour ma mère qui a jamais été séparée de
son mari ne jamais en plus de 50 ans
presque 60 ans à l'autre jour était avec
un accent à ma mère qui allaient tous
les jours s'est fait dire le 12 ou le 13
mars que les visites étaient
interrompues on l'a on l'a pas revu mon
ami la très très très grande chance
d'avoir une bénévole qui qui a fait une
escale avec lui on a pu le voir sur
skype deux qui partent évidemment il
était couché pas très conscient mais là
les bénévoles nous disait que quand il
entendait nos voix mais s'il faut faire
bouger
il y avait quand même une réaction
[Musique]
on a réduit même rester à côté de lui
parce que quand mon mari était malade là
je voulais vraiment j'appelais mais
c'est pour le supplier gist et de
motoriser de venir à son chevet mais
tout cela c'était pas possible même si
il était là de coucher mais peut-être
été écoutés mais mme lavoie
b nous écouter mais le téléphone aussi
n'étaient même pas autorisés au lait
kamerhe de très loin je voulais qu'on
puisse mettre même les téléphones à son
oreille que j'ai pas que je lui parle
mais même cela l'était les fonds
n'étaient même pas autorisés d'entrée
dallaire chambre
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
on n'a pas pu l'accompagner pour son
dernier voyage puis même s'il n'était
plus ou moins conscient évidemment la
fin ben je pense que ce rituel
d'accompagner une personne est important
c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce qu'on
dépouille
donc si cette acceptation les qui est
difficile je pense qu'on peut être en
paix avec le fait qu'ils soient partis
qui souffre plus j'ai fait son bout de
chemin mais la paix est difficile à
avoir avec la façon de saintes il pas
ainsi qu'ils quittent souvent qu'on est
polluée à prier
quand ils m'ont appelé qu'il a fait
l'hémorragie cérébrale
je suis rentré dans sa chambre gd tenais
dans mes bras gély expliqué d'essayer de
s'accrocher la passe qui regarde moi je
suis un set comment je vais faire avec
tous ses enfants et vivre et la
grossesse seul
je me sentais coupable on n'était pas
bien protégé ce suite à sac et ma
famille a été présenté dès la crevette
je n'ai pas pu protéger ma famille qui
m'a créé des masses qui marquent des
jaquettes d'hôpital et jaquettes des
protections là ont manqué ça je me dis
quand même aux calendes à la gaîté pays
vraiment riche
comment on pouvait pas nous protéger
nous devions maintenant tous ces masques
d'où vient tous ces masques je vous fait
mal encore oui
ça a été une violence psychologique
on dirait que j'avais besoin d' excuses
ou de quelqu'un qui dit qu'ils prennent
la responsabilité qui dit ok ça va mal
on a mal géré et maintenant retroussons
nos manches faisons quelque chose pour
les ch et cdd
[Musique]
j'ai encore beaucoup de colère sur la
façon où cette crise l'oeil kg et sur la
façon où on elle laissait mourrir ces
personnes âgées le
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup prendre soin des autres
mais le mal est tombé j'ai perdu mon
mari comme ça kostellic déjà
je pense que c'est important surtout pas
oublier de passer à autre chose qu'un
convoi se remettra à vivre un voyage et
je pense que c'est un point d'histoire
du québec qui qu'il faudra pas oublier
pour qu'elle serve de leçon
la petite est venus à changer la routine
dans la maison j'ai donné les preneurs
et prennent un réseau d eau père elle
s'appelle désir et habitat c'est une
enquête qui avait beaucoup d rêver et
qui n'a même pas pu réaliser ce qu'il
voulait faire
les enfants n'arrêtent pas de parler de
lui même les plus jeunes à chaque fois
d'aider ma maman ou un papa
des fois même si je ne donne pas la
réponse directement a été papa est au
ciel dit oui il est aussi
[Musique]